our next speaker
actually i first met him years ago at a
paella party in washington dc that's
first time we met each other and
despite his
well-known
well-known-ness well consider that a
word despite his his fame
there are actually 60 people
in the united states named david shore
and three of them
are exactly
30 years old
and work in progressive politics
so despite him being one of a kind he is
one of three and one of 60.
everyone please welcome david
real honor to uh to be here and present
to you all uh you know even though most
of most of my shop at this point use
this python i am uh the lone uh i mean
not the lone all of the bayesians or the
lone are holdouts our holds a very
special place in my heart and you know i
think is the basis of most of the things
that we discover
so this talk is uh going to be about
politics hopefully uh people still like
hearing about politics and in particular
i'm going to talk a little bit about the
work that we did in 2020 and uh you know
obviously uh we're still doing the same
kind of stuff
so
the first is uh who are we uh you know
i'm one of the co-founders at blue rose
research uh and so the first thing is it
was founded by alumni of the obama 2012
campaign uh and their analytics team
specifically which at the time was known
as the cave uh in 2020 we worked with
basically every uh 2020 democratic
presidential campaign during the
primaries most of the major party
committees in super pacs and most
outside groups which is a fancy way of
saying groups like labor unions planned
parenthood et cetera
the kinds of problems that we try to
solve are
election forecasting resource allocation
predictive modeling content testing and
attribution uh uh which is a lot uh and
and keeps us very busy in doing that uh
we conduct a thousand we like in 2020 uh
i think with the exact number as we
conducted 6 000 rcts on over 6 million
people
we helped allocate hundreds of millions
of dollars worth of media spend
and we produced a forecast for every
single house senate governor
presidential ballot measure and state
legislative race in the country and in
doing that had to score billions of rows
per day uh and train on millions of rows
per day
the actual team as of right now is about
seven machine learning engineers three
data scientists
it's unclear what the division between
those two are but those are the titles
two bayesian statisticians seven
software engineers and four political
operatives
so
just uh what is it that analytics and
data science and politics actually does
uh i'd say there's kind of we have a
boring unromantic way to look at it is
there's kind of three core questions uh
what races are close and where should i
spend my money uh what messaging should
i base my campaign about on what should
i talk about what creative works what
creative doesn't work and then once you
decide what races you're going to focus
on and what you're going to talk about
how do you actually reach voters
and how do you target uh and all of
those things you know coming out of 2016
you know were broken um in some way uh
traditional survey research doesn't work
super well anymore uh as i think any
observers of polling can tell uh
you know the way that campaigns
historically figured out what worked and
what didn't was by asking small groups
and i mean like six or seven people uh
to self-report how how much they liked
different things which has
problems um and you know traditionally
and uh you know the way that campaigns
talk to people you know hasn't changed
in 30 years um
so
just to talk through each of each of
these uh one by one or at least two of
these um this is a graph uh going back
to 2016 you know kind of all of our
happy places i suppose um uh it has a
lot going on every single bar is net
spending by electoral vote segmented out
by uh by state in the battleground
states and you know what you can see is
that uh
even though hillary clinton had about
three times more money overall than
donald trump uh donald trump outspent
hillary clinton in the tipping point
state that actually decided the election
substantially which is quite bad uh in
and the reason you know why this
happened was basically that all of the
polls uh showed that uh wisconsin uh
wasn't going to be close
this is you know in general public
polling has stopped working
over the past six years or so and
the root cause of this
is that uh survey response rates are a
lot lower than they used to be
polling
working is fundamentally dependent on an
exchangeability assumption that the
people who answer your surveys are the
same as the people who don't uh once you
uh control for the things that you
control for and survey takers have now
become so strange that the traditional
set of things that people control for
are no longer enough uh
the answer to this uh is either to get
people to take more surveys which is
very hard or to control for more things
and unfortunately uh traditional uh
uh traditional waiting techniques fail
when you need to control for 20 things
instead of four things uh which you know
leads you to using biased estimators and
all this other stuff
um
so
uh
you know i i think this slide originally
uh was immediately before the 2020
election uh but basically uh what you
can a lot of people coming out of 2018
thought that polling was fixed but what
you can see is that here this is showing
a polling bias by state in 2018 and in
2016 and you see a pretty consistent
error pattern in 2020 also if you made a
similar graph would look identical just
shift it down
um so talking about messaging i'd say
the highest impact thing we've done is
that we've built out the infrastructure
to do rcts um
of tv advertisements in 2020 we tested
every single democratic and republican
ad that went on the air uh you know what
we found was that roughly 20 percent of
ads uh that democrats made made people
more likely to vote for republicans and
uh generally speaking the more people in
the office liked the ads the worst they
did so underrated theory of change is
find those ads and not show them to
people
so big picture just to describe what we
actually do
i'd say that we have
we do a lot of surveys we survey
millions of people i think we surveyed
about 6 million people in 2020 and
something like 3 million in 2021 so far
uh then we have a voter file of uh every
single person in the country and a
variety of first party data from uh
from uh campaigns uh
the democratic party has over the course
of the last 30 years contacted roughly
186 million people at least once
obviously some people much more than
once and some of those people quite far
away the database administration
archaeology is fun there are the
minnesota democratic party has roughly
half a million michael dukakis ids from
1988 that somehow were stored though
obviously minnesota democratic party is
unsurprisingly better at data management
than other states
and big picture what we do is that we
fit models on our survey data and then
we and then we score
basically every person in the country
and that's kind of you know the big big
picture of what we actually do is fit
those models so
why is this hard um the first is that
politics uh has a lot of structure um
you know there's a
voting behavior is uh
you know driven by a bunch of highly
correlated yet distinct factors like
ethnicity socioeconomic class religion
etc many of which are themselves blatant
and that we don't get to observe
directly the relative importance of all
of these correlated factors can vary a
lot across space and time and uh because
we have to do all of this pooling and
because surveys are expensive um you
know we have to do a lot of
regularization across time and space and
context the other issue is that our data
is very biased um our you know
mathematically our training sets are
very different than our scoring sets uh
people who take surveys are incredibly
weird um and we have to adjust for
things like uh added attitudes toward
the bible or social uh social trust or
attitudes toward corporal punishment in
order to make survey takers even kind of
resemble the overall public
and then you know the other point is
that even though uh you know we're
fitting models in order to do all of our
inference uh our actual objective
functions uh are not related to auc um
you know there are uh lots of things
that do not affect the overall
performance of the model you know one
example is that in
you know southern west virginia there
are an enormous number of people i think
in west virginia's third congressional
district something like 55 percent of
people are registered democrats even
though
uh
obama i think joe biden got about 18
percent of the vote there and uh it's
very easy for a variety of models to get
that wrong and getting it wrong because
not that many people live there uh ends
up not impacting your aoc but if you end
up allocating millions of dollars into a
place um that isn't actually close then
uh that's actually quite bad and the
other point is that we are trying to
estimate a lot of effects that are quite
small
but unfortunately sometimes uh can can
become quite large and then there's
another point um you know just to talk
about this bullet is that uh
barack obama got 52 percent of the vote
of the two-party vote in 2012 and
hillary clinton got
percent and uh that 0.9 percent drop is
not very large but clearly ended up
mattering a great deal to the world and
all of us
just to talk about uh
some of these non-response issues uh
and and how they can end up impacting
accuracy uh here we're looking at social
trust using the gss's social trust
question uh you know they basically ask
people do you think that people can be
trusted or do you think that people uh
cannot be trusted and uh you know what
you can see
is that among folks uh who trust the
people around them that group swung
toward democrats from 2012 to 2016. well
uh regardless of education group but if
you look at folks who do not trust the
people around them
then uh that group as a whole swung
heavily against us and unsurprisingly
people who trust the people around them
and institutions are much much more
likely to answer phone surveys uh which
is you know one of the big reasons uh
you know why we saw
uh the public why we've seen the
repeated public polling errors that
we've seen
and this kind of shows how there are a
lot of things like this that you have to
account for in order to actually make
public opinion estimates reasonably
accurate
another big
issue uh is that uh you know there are a
lot of deviations um from linearity
across context so this is a fun table
that shows uh basically two-way support
uh for clinton as well as a three-way
ideology
by race and religiousity and education
and what you can see is that there are a
lot of deep interactions here
where
uh you know just to call out some of
them uh clinton percent uh is highly
non-sensitive uh among african americans
to all of these things but but when you
look at identifying as a liberal
actually uh african americans and white
folks are relatively exchangeable with
respect to religiosity and education
when predicting whether or not you
identify as liberal even if that's not
true um for uh for clinton
other fun examples are that if you uh
if you are
uh
if you are white then generally speaking
uh going from the highest level of
religiosity to the lowest one uh
generally speaking it makes you more
supportive uh of democrats by very large
amounts but among african-americans the
opposite is true generally speaking
highly religious african-americans are
more democratic even if they are more
conservative
than uh than secular ones and you know
that has a lot to do with the historical
context of black churches and other
things other fun examples of this are
that having a college degree generally
speaking among white people makes you
more liberal but if you are a uh
if you are highly religious then having
a college degree makes you kind of
understand that you're supposed to be
republican and actually has the opposite
sign and just to say all of these
numbers are based on surveys of roughly
two or three million people so all of
these differences that you see are
statistically significant
which is fun um
another fun example of this is that uh
there's still
a lot of regional variation in politics
across both space and context so here
i'm showing in florida and west virginia
two-way democratic vote share for the
presidential race in 2016 and then the
senate race in 2018 and what you can see
here is that in florida
party registration closely tracks both
presidential vote and senate vote but in
west virginia where a very large
fraction of people are still registered
democrats even though it's now a highly
republican state
hillary clinton lost
registered democrats
because a lot of those registered
democrats have since changed party but
joe manchin who was the governor because
they still remember who he is and like
him those registered democrats still
vote for him um even though uh you know
even though they uh
even though they're still even though
they're republicans federally and there
are a lot of these kind of things and we
have to detect them across you know the
literally thousands of races that exist
in u.s politics um you know another big
thing uh is you know this is this is a
graph from 2012 uh where we compare
basically uh the actual you know the gal
weekly gallup polling for the
presidential race versus uh you know our
internal tracker which was based on
modeling and a bunch of other things and
you know what you can see is that the
vast majority if you actually do a
decomposition of variance uh about 95 of
the variance in public polls is either
sampling air or pulsar bias
and only five percent of that uh ends up
being public opinion and that's
something that is uh is very hard and
annoying because measuring
small effects in a highly noisy context
is uh annoying and difficult and hard
but even though like if you go over here
throughout the entire campaign uh the
every public opinion stayed within a one
point range sometimes things can change
very quickly so this is showing support
for joe biden in the democratic primary
uh between nevada and super tuesday and
you know what you can see is that after
the south carolina primary uh joe biden
uh improv
had saw his support increase by
something like
30
over the course of literally three days
um you know we were doing uh we were
surveying at this point uh i think
thousands of people um every day and we
could see that his support was
increasing by about a third of a percent
per hour um and so that's a real problem
if you're fitting bayesian models highly
parametric bayesian models sometimes
stuff like this happens and you need
your systems to be robust to that even
if they very rarely happen
and then you know uh it turns out doing
all of this different work really does
lead to materially better forecasts um
you know here we show uh comparing to
538 you know we've had roughly half the
mean squared error of 538 in our last
two election cycles generally speaking
our september forecasts are more
accurate than uh than public pollings uh
election day forecasts and you can see
that you know in the democratic primary
we also did quite well compared to our
competitors here
so just to talk through some challenges
doing data science in politics
you know the first
is that and i think this is probably
common is that business questions from
clients you know things like what do we
do about georgia um usually lack a
straightforward mapping to a
well-defined statistical question but if
you focus on problems that are
well-defined uh then that heavily limits
your relevance and your impact and uh
even when well defined uh there are a
lot of important questions that are
impossible to answer with certainty um
you know there are
one big just for example one big problem
that is important to what we do is
allocating tv ad spend and you know we
do our the best that we can
econometrically to estimate things like
you know the decay of ad spend or the
overall treatment effects or all of
these other things
but there's a lot of
a lot of things that are impossible to
know and we have to be willing to
step back on parametric models of the
world and do the best that we can in
order to avoid decision paralysis
because at the end of the day there's
500 million dollars it has to be spent
and arguing about instruments um you
know ultimately uh doesn't do anything
and then the other point um and this is
something that i've evolved a lot on is
i remember in you know 2012 when i was
20 years old i uh i really resented i
think a lot of the pointy-headed bosses
i guess or the old school consultants
who you know didn't have a background in
social science or statistics or math um
but looking back you know i think that
80 of my disagreements with them um uh
with 10 years of experience and more
data and everything i i think the 80 of
the time they were right and uh and
they were right and i was wrong uh and
so i think big lesson there is that
you know in the real world in real
organizations it is very hard to rise to
the top and even if folks don't know
about math or social science or
statistics they actually they actually
do have uh quite a bit of important
wisdom and ignoring them is a bad idea
all right
so just to talk about stan and r uh you
know all of our production models are
bayesian which is very exciting all of
our time series tools are fully in stan
uh you know we in terms of the actual
nuts and bolts of what we do uh
generally we do everything uh with
variational inference in tensorflow
probability uh you know this uh
this generally speaking uh means i mean
we have to do this just because you know
you have millions of rows and hundreds
of columns uh but as i think if anyone
here has ever worked with variational
inference it does not work very well um
and uh we've really had to do a lot of
oracle testing and validation in order
to trust the results and even then it
really does break a lot um unfortunately
doing large scale hierarchical bayesian
modeling is very difficult um all right
well that's the talk thanks again for uh
letting me uh present here and i'll hang
out in the chat if anyone ever wants to
ask any questions or reach out
thank you